i love your stand up i loved you on the
living color that's when i first kind of
like got keyed into you and then you
know you kind of like just kept it going
and then and then with ray i mean did
you glue your eyes shut or something for
that movie yeah they glued my eyeshadow
on on ray charles i would be blind for
12 hours which is weird because you know
you at first you get a little oh wow you
get a little like you get a little
claustrophobic but when i met ray
charles
you want to talk about a boss
really sofa i walk into his studio and
he's walking down the hallway
and i say mr charles you know i i really
want to do the best
thing i can you know to to to do that
let me tell you something if you could
play the blues baby you could do
anything
let's play the blues
so we sat down on on dual pianos and
started playing was he critical of you
or did he go okay
so we're playing right we're playing and
we're doing the blues one and then he
goes into thelonious monk um and so i'm
trying to mirror him on that and then i
hit a wrong note point and he said what
now why the hell would you do that i
said what because to his his ears are so
sensitive yes he's you're offended no
he's like
what you what the hell what that hurts
what the [ __ ] are you doing i said i'm
sorry i didn't i didn't know he said let
me tell you something
the notes are right underneath your
fingers baby
all you got to do that's life life is
hitting the right notes they hit the
right note
and he said i think the kids got it
after we played it right and he walked
but in the movie they didn't let you
sing right you sang to track we we we
let
his voice good because we wanted his
voice on the integrity of that film that
was the right thing
that was all taylor heck but taylor hack
said we want his voice you say hey i
think i could sing these songs i mean i
could you know
but we don't want to you know we don't
want to hulk yet yeah we want to be a
parody we want them to feel the record
when that comes on we want them to go to
a different place
you